[Musica]
conosci te stesso
al tempio di apollo a delfi in grecia è
scritto in carattere cubitale perché
anche socrate più di tremila anni fa
riteneva che fosse una domanda
essenziale a cui dare risposta per
riuscire a capire chi si era le proprie
attitudini i propri limiti e soprattutto
quello che era il significato e la
capacità di progettare un proprio futuro
per l'individuo rispondere a questa
domanda
gli antichi greci possono essere visti
un po fuori moda
o forse no se ci pensiamo bene
provate a pensare che loro dovevano
muoversi fossi in un contesto più simili
di quello che noi ci immaginiamo a
quello che noi viviamo oggi un contesto
fatto di tanti interrogativi un mondo
che cambia velocità vertiginose
l'incapacità di dare delle risposte a
delle domande perché vengono cambiate
questa domanda è su base continuativa e
forse questa capacità può ritornare ci
può ritornare utile l'uomo al centro è
solo un intuizione questo forse ci sono
anche degli elementi pratici che ci
insegnano queste cose me basta pensare
jack ma il fondatore di alibaba laureato
in inglese
l'amministratore delegato di youtube
laureato in filosofia e storia antica
il fondatore di arabi e in b storia
dell'arte quindi risalire al concetto di
uomo al centro e alla ricerca di
conoscenza di se stessi per capire quali
possono essere gli orizzonti è un
pensiero che può servire molto alla
società di oggi e ai giovani di oggi
voglio condividere con voi tre passaggi
essenziali che hanno caratterizzato la
mia vita e dove forse al centro c'era
poco questa esigenza capire i propri
limiti capire quelle che erano le
procreative prerogative per il proprio
per il mio futuro
i tre passaggi partono prima dal fatto
che ho cercato di seguire le mie
passioni
quindi è stato parlato di questo mio
ruolo come presidente della fondazione
cortina 20 21 organizziamo dei mondiali
di sci
abbiamo provato prima di tutto io a
sentirmi a provare a sentirmi utile uno
arriva a 50 anni si è tolto delle
soddisfazioni nel mondo del lavoro
pensa che sia arrivato il momento per
fare qualche cosa che possa essere utile
anche agli altri
il grande evento può essere una grande
occasione ho pensato c'è soprattutto la
mia passione la passione nei confronti
dello sport la passione nei confronti
del dello sci alpino sono un tecnico
federale quindi in qualche maniera mi
sono avvicinato a questo esperimento ed
è un esperimento che è diventato una
realtà che sempre di più mi ha fatto
cambiare e mi ha regalato delle
soddisfazioni
ci siamo dati dei titoli quel giorno ci
siamo dati il titolo di pensare ai
giovani di pensare alle infrastrutture a
luca la comunità locale alla
sostenibilità però abbiamo voluto fare
qualche cosa in più abbiamo voluto
pensare sicuramente a dare il nostro
contributo affinché il paese facesse una
bella figura ma anche a immaginarci ha
delle cose più basiche più essenziale
tipo se la comunità locale non prospera
come può avere continuità un luogo che è
un patrimonio dell'unesco come cortina e
da qui siamo partiti dando un concetto
allargato delle cose nel caso della
sostenibilità per esempio abbiamo
provato a pensare appunto a una
sostenibilità di tipo sociale quella
sostenibilità che permette il lavoro
l'occupazione il lavoro vuol dire la
famiglia la famiglia vuol dire la
comunità e la comunità vuol dire la
società quindi un modo nuovo di fare
delle cose per bene e allargare
l'orizzonte
la passione è un elemento molto
importante un e grant è un elemento
essenziale si possono fare tante cose
nella vita ma senza l'amore e la
passione per il proprio mestiere per la
ricerca di se stessi è molto difficile
farle bene poi c'è stato un altro grande
passaggio di discontinuità nella mia
vita mi piace chiamarli passaggi di
discontinuità sono quei momenti in cui
magari fai le cose non oggi fai le cose
che magari fanno prendere paura tua
madre perché ai 26 anni
sei tornato da harvard hai già fatto un
percorso innovativo per quanto riguarda
l'esperienza della tua famiglia ritorni
sei ricco di una tesi con michael porter
michael porter questo grande professore
ecco parlando di storia interessante un
grande professore che ha avuto la
fortuna con la quale ho avuto la
confortola di lavorare negli stati uniti
che a un certo punto sta quasi per
essere espulso dall ateneo di harvard
sta per essere espulso perché lui
differentemente da altri studiosi non
pubblica e quella un'unità di misura
essenziale in realtà lui non pubblica
perché sta raccogliendo dei dati che
vuole dove lui vuole dimostrare
l'analogia tra settori diversi
stiamo parlando immaginatevi della fine
degli anni ottanta all'inizio degli anni
90 quindi se tu parli del settore della
chimica non ha niente a che fare con il
settore dell'abbigliamento non c'entrano
niente dal punto di vista della
codificazione naturale nella gestione
delle imprese
lui arriva invece con una visione
innovativa di attenzione c'è
alla fine l'uomo al centro quindi
durante i momenti di discontinuità i
cicli aziendali quello che conta è come
uno riesce ad anticipare il cambiamento
e questo è scorrelato rispetto ai
settori o per meno non sempre solo
correlato in maniera diretta quindi io
torno ad harvard penso che mi occuperò
di affari di famiglia ea quel tempo
avevamo diversificato come famiglia nel
mondo dell'articolo sportivo nordica
prince e l'azienda va benissimo ma con
mike o diciamo se noi non cambiamo in
fretta e questo lo abbiamo imparato
perché l'abbiamo visto in altri settori
le cose non andranno bene convinto di
essere ascoltato invece giustamente
troppo giovane mi dicono
bravo apprezziamo il tuo coraggio ma tra
te il management prendiamo il management
e l'aglio scopro me stesso
scopro che alla fine sono invece anche
se ho 26 anni e la strada la faccio pur
avendo una rete di protezione economica
che dovrebbe sicuramente un grande
facilitatore ma preferisco prendermi i
miei rischi fondo la mia società
una piccola società che finisce per
essere la prima società di private
equity in italia e dico io voglio
dimostrare che queste analogie esistono
partirò dalle aziende piccole lunga
storia corta questa diventa una società
distruggere di successo oggi gestiamo 2
miliardi di euro
abbiamo 100 mila persone impiegate nelle
nostre partecipazioni e abbiamo
dimostrato ma soprattutto io ho
dimostrato a me stesso quello che
cercavo per essere una persona
soddisfatta e felice capire chi ero io
ho cercato sempre di non fermarmi
in tutto questo quindi oggi affrontiamo
anche un altro tema
affrontiamo il tema della sostenibilità
oggi fare impresa vedete non può più
essere fare dei profitti sempre michael
porter con lo share vaio un nuovo
concetto che invito tutti a conoscere
vuole dare un nuovo tipo di visione a
che cosa vuol dire oggi fare impresa
fare impresa oggi vuol dire avere una
coscienza che all'interno degli
interessi ci devono essere gli interessi
delle comunità locali
ci devono essere gli interessi di
fornitore di chi lavora dentro le
aziende delle famiglie che dipendono
dalle aziende direttamente o
indirettamente del territorio solo così
nel futuro le aziende avranno un
significato per esistere e le aziende
devono cambiare questo paradigma da
essere viste non il male quelle che
inquinano ma quelle che contribuiscono
invece a togliere l'inquinamento delle
nostre vite è un calcolo matematico
se noi pensiamo di farcela con la
filantropia con la responsabilità degli
individui e con le donazioni sicuramente
non ci arriveremo perché i numeri sono
contro di noi con tutto quello che
succede al mondo se invece abbiamo il
coraggio di immaginarci quel tipo di
impresa
ce la possiamo fare nel nostro piccolo
con la mia società
abbiamo voluto uscire dalla nostra zona
di ottimi risultati precedenti
immaginarci proprio questo futuro
diverso
quindi il mio suggerimento è quello di
avere il coraggio di uscire da quello
che conosciamo e al di là del successo
temporaneo pensare in grande pensare in
grande che vuol dire anche avere il
coraggio di andare in zone che non si
conoscono
di recente ma è tornato in mente una
storia molto interessante e molti di voi
conoscono morse per quello che ha
inventato la comunicazione a distanza
però pochi di voi sanno la sua storia
lui nasce da una famiglia umile il padre
fosse era un pastore e
cosa casa però il padre si accorge che
questo ragazzo ha la capacità di
disegnare lui disegna benissimo a la
perfetta vocazione di fare l'artista
quindi con un po di sacrificio e
un'importante borsa di studio da parte
del di yale lui finisce per far ricorso
ai e diventa un bravissimo artista uno
scultore dipinge benissimo a quel tempo
una delle cose più importante che può
fare un pittore è fare il ritratto del
presidente degli stati uniti non
esistono le televisioni quindi l'empatia
che riesce a trasmettere il ritratto
frutto anche delle abilità dell'artista
è un fatto essenziale lui finisce per
fare il ritratto del secondo presidente
degli stati uniti ha così tanto successo
che lo mandano in francia farà il
ritratto di lafayette mentre lui e la
riceve una lettera e scopre che la
moglie molto malata e sta per morire lo
scopre due settimane dopo prende una
nave incontra un tecnico durante la nave
lui è già tutto frastornato e
soprattutto provato dal dolore di non
sapere di non aver saputo per tempo che
la moglie non stava bene lui ritorna
alla moglie già sepolta e lui si ritrova
disperato in questa situazione è il più
grande dispiacere è quello di non aver
saputo e di non aver avuto la notizia
per tempo
quindi si mette a lavorare lui che fa
l'artista assieme a questo che ha
conosciuto nella nave e con un
finanziamento del congresso americano
finiscono per inventare una cosa che ha
cambiato la vita di tutti noi
lui ha avuto il coraggio di pensare in
grande
i giovani tante volte mi chiedono
suggerimenti posso condividere la mia
esperienza le mie emozioni
questo tipo di approccio alla vita che è
anche di tipo filosofico riuscire a dare
un significato oltre quello che si fa e
la materialità di quello che si fa
ecco mi piace condividere un pensiero
che è una condivisione una spiccio un
augurio è un pensiero di don giussani
vi auguro di non stare tranquilli grazie
[Applauso]